I knew that the train station was
somewhere near and it's something I am
an actor and I have autism it's really
hard for people with any disability to
get a large role in a professional
theatre but for the first time in my
life I'm getting to star in a major
professional production
[Music]
you said it was September 12th last year
at first Frank my name is Mickey row and
I am playing Christopher Boone in the
Curious Incident of the dog in the
night-time the Curious Incident of the
dog of the night time is about a boy who
has autism and his adventure that flips
his world upside down I am the first
autistic actor to play Christopher Boone
and I am surprisingly one of the first
autistic actors to play any autistic
character anywhere I've had to be an
actor my whole life to pass as
neurotypical so being an actor comes so
naturally to me I used scripting in my
daily life for example if I went to a
coffee shop I might say to the barista
hi can I please have a medium drip
coffee how's your day going today has it
been busy today and then regardless of
what they say it's been busy or slow I
can then say oh would do you like it
better when it's busier when it's slow
so that way I can kind of script my life
so I don't have to deal with social
interactions thank you so much have a
great rest of your day
[Applause]
in rehearsal is my happy spot because I
have the lines I'm playing a character
everyone else is playing a role be it
another character in the player director
during five-minute breaks or 10-minute
breaks or lunch breaks is when you feel
less comfortable you don't have a
specific role during that time
which makes it confusing for someone on
the spectrum on stage there's often
bright light shining on you and loud
noises that come out of nowhere as sound
cues but you've rehearsed all these
things in advance and you know where
each sound cue is happening because it
happens in the exact same place every
night so it almost feels like you're in
control of those things and because you
know what to expect you're in on the
magic you would have to talk to other
people though from Mission Control but
we would do that your radio link up in a
TV monitor it's so rare for any actor
with any disability to get to play a
leading role in any production let alone
a professional traveling production I
get to show people that people with
disabilities we get the job done
[Applause]